so
[Music]
spirit is the content of its
consciousness at first in the form of
pure substance or is the content of its
pure consciousness
this element of thought is the movement
of descending into existence or into
individuality the middle term between
these two is their synthetic connection
the consciousness of passing into
otherness or picture thinking as such
the third moment is the return from
picture thinking and otherness or the
element of self-consciousness itself
these three moments constitute spirit
it's dissociation and picture thinking
consistent it's existing in a specific
or determinate mode but this
determinateness is nothing else than one
of its moments its complete movement is
there for this to diffuse its nature
throughout each of its moments as in its
native element since each of these
spheres completes itself within itself
this reflection of one sphere into
itself is at the same time the
transition into another picture thinking
constitutes the middle term between pure
thought and self-consciousness as such
and is only one of the specific or
determinant forms at the same time
however as we've seen
its character that of being a synthetic
connection is diffused throughout all
these elements and is their common
determinateness
here in paragraph 767
hegel is bringing a lot of things
together in a rather metaphysical
way it's it's fairly abstract so we have
to do some you know thinking between the
lines about what it is that he's talking
about in the next paragraph of course
he's going to get a little bit more
concrete and refer us back to
some of the previous sections and we
could say
that if we had to pick out what is the
center point of it it is this
middle term mitta right which is for
stellang or
representation picture thinking
imagination right and
what he's talking about here though are
three moments of
spirit of geist and this is you know the
phenomenology of spirit so it's really
central to what we're trying to
make sense of and he's telling us about
these three
moments and he says that these three
constitute
spirit now is he talking about
constituting spirit throughout the
entire dialectical development of
consciousness and the phenomenology no
this this is spirit at this point but
spirit articulated in one of its highest
forms
in religion and specifically in one of
the most developed forms
of religion the revealed religion
and revealed religion that actually has
for us a revelation not just coming down
from on high
uh coming straight from god itself but
rather revelation
in a person so so christianity
and these these three different
moments are all going to be
spirits
and each one is going to each of these
these different domains you could say or
spheres as he says completes itself
within itself but they're all connected
to each other there's a transition
that is going on and he comes back to
this picture thinking uh as being the
middle term at the the uh
towards the end of the paragraph right
picture thinking constitutes the middle
term the mitta between pure thought and
self-consciousness as such but then he
he sort of relativizes that so we're
going to come to that so let's let's see
how he
lays all of these out
at the beginning and you could get a
little bit confused because hegel
doesn't say
one two three instead he lays out some
stuff and then talks about a third
moment and then talks about these three
moments but it's really not that
difficult to see what what is coming
together here what is the first moment
well the first moment has to do with
pure substance or thought or
consciousness right he says
spirit is the content of its
consciousness so bavustine the
consciousness
at first in the form of pure substance
and then he says or
so this means this is equivalent here
is the content of its pure consciousness
how should we understand this
the element of thought denkins right
something that has been driving this
this cart the entire time something that
we saw earlier we've got you know
thought essence existence
uh and uh being and then we've also got
substance subject self
right so there's all these these these
things that are being connected together
so here we've got the one side pure
thought right
pure thought of what
well you know the religious object the
divine what it is that is
most essential
uh the supreme being
and then this descends her onto
zuschteigen
going under
going downward
it descends into existence design or
individuality einselenheit okay so
that's the
religious
being taking on flesh becoming incarnate
and
being a
person in not in the sense of the
persons of the trinity is the second
person of the christian trinity but
being a person in the sense that we're
used to somebody who can interact with
you right somebody who has agency
somebody who has a history right so he
says that um this is that that that
at first
the middle term between these two is
their synthetic connection the
consciousness of passing into otherness
or picture thinking is such alright so
there we've got our
second moment
and the middle term what it is that
allows this descent
is what he's calling the synthetic and
this is you know just a
cognate of synthesis
so hegel is deliberately using this word
synthetic here he's not using the word
synthesis though right so you know
whatever stuff you've come across with
hegel's all about threes yeah there's
three here and it's thesis antithesis
synthesis
well this is interesting right because
the
synthesis
is not simply taking the you know thesis
and antithesis the two opposites and
coming up with a better form of them no
it's happening right there in the middle
and this is not a synthesis this is a
fair binding with synthetic qualifying
the fair binding or connection
so that's a
important thing to keep in mind and this
is a middle term
what's going on here
we're still dealing with consciousness
consciousness
of passing into
otherness anders vietnam becoming other
right
so passing works
becoming other
how does one become other in terms of
religion well you know i mean we've got
the worshiper the believer on the one
hand and we've also got the
religious
object the person uh in this case the
anointed one the christ right teacher
healer
all sorts of other things that are that
are going on there and this is as hegel
is saying
picture thinking as such
picture thinking representation for
stellang not conceptual
not be grief or you know be griefly
but rather uh for stellen or forstellung
or for gestalt all of these things that
have to do with the way in which we
represent
to ourselves so this is the second
moment what's the third moment
the third moment is not a synthesis it
is a return a rook care
going back a turning
back towards
what
towards spirit
spirit becoming explicitly conscious of
itself and now we're no longer dealing
just with consciousness
we are explicitly dealing with
self-consciousness right the return into
the element of self-consciousness as
such uh self-consciousness itself zelpst
then he goes on and says okay now these
three moments constitute spirit
it's dissociation and picture thinking
into the second mode right which is how
it's descending into existence
its dissociation and picture thinking
consists in its existing in a specific
or determinate mode but this
determinateness
is nothing else than one of its moments
one of whose moments one of spirit's
moments
spirit needs all three of these
we're not just jumping ahead in some
sort of mysticism to you know what is
the real
essence of this leave all this this
extra crap behind no no this is all
important and hegel goes on here to say
that
it's complete movement again who's
complete movement spirits
spirit's complete movement is this to
diffuse its nature throughout each of
its moments
as in its native element spirit is in
each of these
it is not that representation is geislow
spiritless
it may be
you know grislos it's not yet conceptual
but it's not
it's not spirit lacking or anything like
that any more than this
initial moment
the entering of the eternal into time to
use uh you know a lapidary formula
coming from kierkegaard's philosophical
fragments
that is also spirit
he says each of these
completes itself within itself
the reflection of one sphere into itself
is at the same time the transition into
another so this
reflecting on itself
we could say becoming self-conscious in
a way
makes us conscious of the middle term
of the four stellang
thinking about the forest telling the
middle term the representation the
becoming other
leads us to the return
to the element of self-consciousness
notice he doesn't say to return to
self-consciousness we're
self-consciousness the entire time
we just didn't realize it but the
element of self-consciousness and what
is this element
what did self-consciousness teach us
well
self-consciousness is self-consciousness
in another for another right you don't
have self-consciousness all by itself so
there's it's relational
it's also desire
hunger begin
and desire for what
honor cannon recognition that's all
implicit here in this anyway he goes on
and he says picture thinking constitutes
the middle term between pure thought
and self-consciousness as such so now
it's not just a middle term between
thought and existence or individuality
in this first moment it is also the
mediating term the mita the means
between this return to
self-consciousness and the
descent into
individuality on the part of pure
thought
so he goes on and he says it's only one
of the specific or determinate forms
so there's there's multiple forms here
at the same time
however as we've seen its character
once again hegel uses this
deliberately chosen term
a synthetic connection not a synthesis
a synthetic connection a connection that
is binding things together bringing them
together sun in the greek is what we're
getting uh synthesis from
is diffused throughout all these
elements and it is their common
determinateness now what does that mean
even in the return the return is not a
complete abandonment
of picture thinking
it is going to be doing something
further with the picture thinking
because the picture thinking he says uh
is its character of being a synthetic
connection is diffused throughout all
these elements it is their common
determinateness so we're not yet
passed for stellar
the content itself which we have to
consider has partly been met with
already as the idea of the unhappy and
the believing consciousness but in the
former it has the character of a content
produced from consciousness for which
spirit yearns and in which spirit cannot
be satiated or find rest because it is
not yet in itself its own content or is
not the substance of it
in the believing consciousness on the
other hand the content was regarded as
the selfless being of the world or as
essentially an objective content of
picture thinking of a picture thinking
that simply flees from reality and
consequently is without the certainty of
self-consciousness which is separated
from it partly by the conceit of knowing
and partly by pure insight
the consciousness of the community on
the other hand possesses the content for
its substance just as the content is the
certainty of the community's own spirit
there is a lot of reference to content
that is in halt in paragraph 768 and
there's an interesting comparison going
on between what we can call previous
shapes or gestalton
of religious consciousness ways in which
consciousness has
understood
or misunderstood itself in relation to
its object
of religion and hegel is saying that at
this point something new
is arriving on the scene so if we want
to think about just pausing on the text
for a moment some of the implications of
this
and we we think about you know hegel's
project of
bringing philosophy into history looking
at the historical development of
consciousness what we should think about
is there being some
overlap
between these these three different main
shapes of religious consciousness
religious consciousness in relation to
christianity and perhaps other forms of
theism as well
so that it's not as if first in in
history there was the unhappy
consciousness and then only much much
later did we have faith the believing
consciousness and then only much later
do we have this consciousness of the
community no these are all possibilities
but one of them is a little bit more
possible at a given point in time so the
development of christian
doctrine and community itself i think
for hegel would be
important in this so he tells us this
content which we have to consider
has partly and that's a key term right
there partly been met with already as
the idea
of the
unhappy and believing consciousness
two different uh shapes of consciousness
right so
partly right we are not radically
inventing things you know this has been
dealt with to some degree
previously
but
you could say that its fullness hasn't
been brought out and if we go back to
the previous paragraph and a little bit
further as well
the
picture thinking
that is going on in these earlier shapes
has turned out to be
not quite adequate to the demands of
religion
the spirit that wants to know itself
through religion
so first we have the unhappy
consciousness this is the entire section
ending the self-consciousness section
after stoicism after skepticism after
the whole struggle to the death and the
master slave dialectic the uh unhappy
consciousness is the culmination of the
self-consciousness section
and he tells us that it has a certain
character
it's a way of translating bishdemong
right a certain thing that it's
resonating with responding
to and what is the
essential
structure of the unhappy consciousness
well we've talked about this before he
says it has the character of a content
an inhalt produced from consciousness
right and so that produced hereford
brockton right
spirit consciousness projects the
religious object out there as the
eternal into
a beyond the yanzites from the
here this you know yan
d sites right there's this this
unbridgeable gap and there's all these
attempts to bridge the gap and to get
there
and
at the same time that spirit is without
realizing it producing and projecting
this religious object out there
uh it's also yearning
for you know it is
the way in which this content is being
described it is
yearned for
right yearned for by who by the
religious believer
who is spirit at this point
and he says that spirit cannot be
satiated it cannot it cannot find its
satisfaction
or find rest why not
because it is not yet in itself its own
content or is not the substance of it
right
so it projects something out there
as being not yet as being other than it
and it's going to seek for it its
satisfaction which is really itself
a reconciliation
within that and it never gets there
right
it gets all sorts of things
and it tries all sorts of means but none
of them are as effective as it needs to
be okay so that's the unhappy
consciousness
what about the believing consciousness
the glaubenda
right this is the thing that gets
discussed in the spirit section
uh in relation as faith right lauber in
relation to the enlightenment and
insight and it's something that is going
to ultimately
get left behind
and why
so he says in the believing
consciousness
the content was regarded as the selfless
zelps loser not unselfish but lacking a
self lacking agency lacking the
possibility of knowing itself the
selfless
being they is in essence of the world
or another way of thinking about this
the objective
uh
content in halt right objective gig and
stanley cup
uh of picture thinking
picture thinking uh forced of them right
so the person who has faith
believes in things they believe in these
representations
which don't really match up to the world
faith ends up being you could say
more or less like an extra world that's
tacked on and it doesn't and here's
here's a key term right he says that
this four stellang flees reality now
it's reality there vehicle kite the
world that we actually know right you
know religious people like this oh i
have faith that this is going to happen
and this means this and you're like
okay that's cool uh how does that
connect up with your everyday life well
it doesn't really connect up with my
everyday life i have my belief over here
and then i go off to work over here and
my you know playing around with my my
companions over here and my drinking and
screwing over here and all this
compartmentalized world right which
isn't really a world and faith becomes
essentially fable of course it becomes
quite dangerous when faith turns into
people trying to remake the world
according to their crazy stories think
about you know all the damage that the
left behind nonsense novels did with
american evangelicalism uh you know
helping to sort of rot their brains with
this this drivel about post-apocalyptic
this and post-apocalyptic that i mean
those of us who saw these things coming
out were like well who reads this crap
well you know
that's a particular
gestalt of the believing consciousness
in our own time and this happened in
many other cases as well you know uh
during the reformation you know um
in in a lot of different ways and that's
one side of the believing consciousness
hegel's not really picking out on that
he's instead focusing on the
ineffectuality
of the believing consciousness why it is
that faith can be eroded by as he's
going to say
pure insight right
so he goes on and he says um
this is a picture thinking that flees
from reality and consequently is without
the certainty of self-consciousness
it lacks
certainty
it has a kind of
folk you know uh
you know false certainty
but a certainty they can't really stand
up to
scrutiny particularly self-scrutiny
start having doubts and then you know
that faith
crumbles
and it's eroded by its own conceit of
knowing it's itel kite right it's it's
you could say vanity of pretending that
it knows when it doesn't know and by
pure insight that looks into it and says
there's really just representations here
that are
not connected with vehicle with reality
now
what do we have beyond that
now he talks about the consciousness of
the
community
the gemini right
uh commander uh should be
and the consciousness of the community
at this point is
what we're developing in this revealed
religion section it's not just the
consciousness of revelation orphan
borrowing you know god revealing god's
self
it's not just god
becoming incarnate
teaching talking loving
dying sacrificing
all of those sorts of things it is the
community the commander
and this is not just a consciousness of
the community
it is also a
self-consciousness of the community that
is developing we
followers of we
believers we
yearners
it's becoming self-conscious
of its own activity of its own
involvement where are we going with this
of its own
connection with divinity so he says the
consciousness on the community possesses
the content for its substance
unhappy consciousness didn't realize
that the substance was it
believing consciousness couldn't provide
a substance that's why it gets torn
apart by by pure insight this
provides a substance and he says
just as the content is the certainty
of spirit but what spirit of the
community's
own spirit now there's a really
interesting corollary to this can you
take this and and sort of like strip it
away and abstract from it and do it just
on your own
no you still need a community there
don't you and this is where we could say
the religious
and the social and the political
and the philosophical and the economic
and pick all these other things where we
humans relate to each other are going to
be coming together hegel's not spelling
that out here in this this paragraph but
that would be you could say one of the
implications of where
this is all going
you